it feels good to be a gangster who can
jump to conclusions but is that just as
true in 2023 as it was in 1999 let's
find out why we've yet to see an office
space too
unlike so many other sequels that never
happened the lack of an Office Space 2
isn't due to just one particular reason
office space didn't exactly light up the
box office when it hit theaters in
February 1999 but that's only a small
part of the picture as it eventually
became a cult classic when it was
released on DVD so it could have gotten
a sequel on the strength of its home
viewing popularity but it wasn't so
simple at that point by the early 2000s
Jennifer Aniston was a bankable movie
star so it would have made it difficult
to reunite the entire cast but the
bigger problem was that office space
writer director Mike Judge was
ambivalent about the entire idea of
making a follow-up film in 2009 he was
talking with the Times Union to promote
his new movie extract when the topic of
a potential office space sequel came up
when he was asked if he would consider
directing it he responded I don't think
so maybe there was a time I would have
thought about it but there have been
really great TV shows the British the
office and the American version
essentially judge realized that he'd
have nothing new to say about
office-based workplaces and he's
continued to insist that he's not
interested as he told Rolling Stone in
2011 I just can't see it there's been so
many good shows like the British office
and the American office so much good
cubicle stuff also it's been too long I
don't know nevertheless a small but
devoted office space fan base has
continued to express its love for the
film with an enduring passion that's
unusual for a mid-budget comedy
while fans have been crying out for a
sequel to office space for a couple of
decades the cast members seem less
enthused for example Gary Cole who
played condescending boss Bill Lundberg
was asked during a 2017 interview on
Larry King live if there could ever be a
second movie to which he replied I think
that would have to do with Mike and I
don't think Mike is interested in that
so and
is not alone
played lead character Peter Gibbons
feels
appearance on talk stoop he was
promoting his TV shows Loudermilk and a
million little things but of course the
topic of an office space sequel also
came up once is there ever going to be a
sequel well I don't think so according
to Livingston there are two main reasons
working against a follow-up as he
explained I think if there were going to
be a sequel it would have happened by
now and the second reason is Mike Judge
has just never been the person to do
something because it would be lucrative
to do it it always ends up being
lucrative but it seems to always start
out with some out of left field crazy
genius idea that Mike has as far as
Livingston can tell judge simply doesn't
have the creative inspiration to write a
sequel I think Mike probably feels like
we did that we already explored that
well I don't have anything more to say
about that
so the office space actors have
speculated about their writer director's
lack of enthusiasm for a new movie but
what does Mike Judge himself have to say
quite a bit actually and it may surprise
some fans to hear that at one point he
actually was ready to work on a
follow-up as he explained to Mass live
in 2009 at one point a while back I
considered doing a sequel to office
space but I wouldn't do one now once
again judge cited the success of certain
iconic workplace TV comedies that
explored all the same themes as his
movie and how that dampened his
enthusiasm for revisiting the world of
office drones he also noted I kind of
feel like I wouldn't want to go back to
it at this point and that's not the only
reason that judge is reluctant to work
on a follow-up as he revealed to the rep
in 2015 he had a bad experience with
Executives at Fox while working on a TV
pilot considering all those factors the
window of opportunity has pretty much
closed also not helping with Gary Cole
reprising the role of Lumberg for a
hipchat comedy short according to judge
it was not very well done and the final
nail in the coffee and for the franchise
if you're a loyal fan of Mike Judge you
might have already realized that while
there hasn't been any official office
space sequel there has been a sort of
spiritual follow-up it may not continue
the stories of Peter Michael Bolton and
Samir but 2009's extract is a similar
black comedy about a man and his work it
Stars Jason Bateman as Joel Reynolds the
owner of a company that makes flavor
extracts he's having all kinds of
problems both at work and at home where
he's trapped in an unhappy marriage
extract may offer a different
perspective than office space but it
shares certain sensibilities and is
often considered a companion piece after
all both films were written and directed
by Mike Judge and both flopped at the
box office and while it hasn't developed
into as big of a cult hit as office
space it's still considered by some fans
as the next best thing to a sequel
according to judge it may not appeal to
the same crowd of board office workers
but it definitely takes its aim at a
portion of the frustrated working crowd
as he explained to the Florida Times
Union in 2009 there's probably more
people in cubicles than owning extract
factories but I think anybody who has
people who work for them or who are
buying a house I hope it will catch that
older group of people I mean did you
like invent extract or something
extract isn't the only 21st century Mike
Judge project that's been hailed as a
spiritual office space sequel if you've
been following his career closely it's
clear that there are certain themes
about the plight of the American worker
that he keeps returning to so it's
hardly a surprise that his HBO sitcom
Silicon Valley is considered by many to
be the true follow-up to the 1999 film
office space captured the drudgery of
90s office life but that's a version of
employment that almost doesn't exist
anymore with the way that working
culture has changed it's that Evolution
that Silicon Valley highlights and
because it was created by Mike Judge it
often feels like the truest extension of
the movie that fans have loved for
decades Silicon Valley aired for six
seasons from 2014 to 2019. the story
follows a group of jaded employees at a
northern California Tech startup praised
by critics for its offbeat characters
and its knack for poking fun at
technology and corporate investor
culture the series also mines the
humdrum life of office Stooges for some
top-notch comedy like Office Space
Valley offers an honest look at the
business world and it may indeed be the
closest thing that fans will ever get to
a sequel
it's been more than 20 years since
office space arrived in theaters and it
may be a longer wait still even if Mike
Judge ever does decide to make an actual
sequel but that doesn't mean that fans
haven't gotten a taste of what a second
film would potentially look like
multiple cast members actually got back
together for a mini-sequel of sorts in
the form of a series of Walmart
commercials in 2022 to celebrate Black
Friday reprising their roles where Gary
Cole as Bill Lundberg Ajay Naidu as
uptight programmer Samir Kana Mcenroe as
receptionist Nina Diedrich Bader as
country boy neighbor Lawrence and
Jennifer Emerson as the temp who thinks
everyone has a case of the Mondays even
Michael Bolton got in on the fun not the
Michael Bolton played by David Herman
but the grammy-winning singer of the
same name who played himself as a
staffer at the new initech yeah they
brought me in to improve morale the
commercials were full of fun gags that
recalled some of the best moments from
the film but this reunion wasn't exactly
fully embraced some fans pointed out
that by partnering with a mega
corporation like Walmart the ads were
completely going against the entire
message of the movie Plus without Ron
Livingston Jennifer Aniston or Steven
root returning they didn't quite fully
capture the vibe of the movie though for
some viewers it may have been close
enough to remind us of why they loved
office space so much in the first place
we've heard from the cast and crew of
Office Space over the years about the
challenges of actually making a sequel
happen these issues include coming up
with a good idea the Practical
difficulties of getting the cast back
together and convincing Mike Judge that
it's a worthy Endeavor that doesn't mean
that it can't happen though and now may
actually be the best time for everyone
involved judge has recently returned to
two of his former franchises as Beavis
and Butthead debuted new episodes on
Paramount plus beginning in 2022 and
Hulu announced in 2023 that it was
Reviving King of the Hill so clearly he
can be convinced to return to an old
idea under the right circumstances and
the corporate world of office space
isn't entirely dead and the changes in
that culture in the past couple of
decades could serve as fruitful
inspiration for a new story open Office
layouts video conferencing and remote
work are just some of the topics that
could potentially be lampooned in a
sequel and with the rise of streamers
there's more opportunity than ever for a
mid-budget office comedy to have a
sequel in short an office space
follow-up might be a tough sell for some
involved but there's little doubt that
it could work out if the original cast
and crew get back together and find the
right inspiration
[Music]